Lebanon has been plunged into darkness, after
its two largest power stations were shut down
due to a prolonged fuel shortage. Officials
say the outage will last several days.
It's the latest hardship for people
in Lebanon, where three-quarters of
the population are in poverty due to
soaring prices and record unemployment.
Financial crisis has kept Lebanon’s economy
in the red. And now fuel shortages have
plunged the entire country into darkness.
"The electricity used to be cut off for three
hours. Then recently, we only had three hours
of electricity. Now, there is none at all.”
First the power went out at the Deir Ammar
plant. Then the Zahrani plant went offline.
The outages caused Lebanon’s centrally
generated electrical grid to collapse.
"We are spending our time outside our
homes, so our children can have fun.
The situation is getting steadily worse.
May God protect us from what's coming next."
Many people have come to depend on
private generators that run on diesel,
but that is in short supply
too and it, like most goods,
is becoming pricey. Since 2019, the
Lebanese currency has dropped 90%.
This outage has added more weight to
the burden people must carry here.
"It's affecting me, my house is on the
eleventh floor, I can't go up or down,
sometimes I sleep in the car until 3 or 4
am, so there might be electricity, what can
we do? Look at the life we're living."
The army has agreed to provide 6,000
kiloliters of gas oil, securing
power in Lebanon for just three days.